another uh podcast that talks about
checking women constantly is fresh and
fit now guys I will tell you when I
first started listening to fresh and fit
they would trigger me a lot because I
just thought they were so rude so
disrespectful to the women that came on
the show until I got into their shoes
life is funny I swear life is funny and
then I started doing
um what they did I did a live show like
them and I realized God damn women will
disrespect you ten times you check them
once and they play victim you check them
once and and you're the bad guy you're
the big meanie and I realize that women
will whine and wine and wine and I'm not
even saying I've never done this in my
life I probably have but we live in a
society that men can never check women
for their behavior without being called
toxic manipulative controlling so it's
funny because they used to kind of
trigger me when I would watch them until
I I got red pilled and I realized
they're right about a lot of things so
at what point though does trust factor
into that like let's say for friends
getting married or I don't know her
friends celebrating a birthday there's
15 of her friends going out she wants to
join yeah at what point does trust play
into that where it's like you don't want
to tell them no don't go and hang out
with your friends because you're going
to a club I mean to me that just seems
like well I was I was I say you you
can't control a girl you obviously can't
do that you're gonna stay inside the
only thing you could control is what you
do and how you respond you want to go
cool you're single when you come back
but but there's got to be a line here
right but but no that's not manipulation
at all but but that's how many
boundaries are not acting on that
example
hold on let me get my example sure go
ahead uh one year relationship she's
going out with her friends celebrating a
birthday party sure thing 15 girls are
gonna be there she's known forever you
would tell her no you can't go to that
because you're going to a club I would
tell her you can go and do whatever you
do
but you'll be single when you return but
why why why does it make sense to throw
out a relationship like that that
otherwise is good because if she
respects you she wouldn't have won in
the first place but that seems like more
like an ultimatum that you're placing on
it's not ultimatum she has a choice to
make okay but that's an ultimatum no no
it's like no no she could do it she's
completely free to do whatever she wants
because the thing is is that she's
putting the she's putting the
relationship in a risky situation why
why would she be don't you would you
trust me because let's be honest here
what are nightclubs for well here's the
thing so I will say in general oh okay
okay
in general yeah nightclubs are for
meeting other people because another
daughter
Mommy I have boyfriends that were like
yo boyfriend we didn't even know it's
like Bro funny bachelorette parties
bro oh my gosh yeah a bunch of girls oh
they're just chilling by themselves
before you do it it's a gang of guys in
there in their room and I'm just saying
bro things happen so don't be dumb about
it be smart here's the thing here's the
thing I refuse to give a woman the
comfort of security with me as her
boyfriend while she can simultaneously
and behave as though she's single I have
boundaries and standards and this is
what it comes with it because the thing
is is that if a girl truly respects you
she's not going to want to go to the
club she's not going to want to be
around her friends that want to go ahead
and do all this extra stuff because yeah
like like she's not going to want to
behave like she's single when she's with
a man that she actually admires and
respects and my thing is if she wants to
go to Club that's cool but you no longer
are in a relationship with me because
I'm not going to look stupid sitting at
home while you go out and behave like
you're single that's this is the first
point I actually would say I have a
pretty strong disagreement fair enough
look if you trust your partner and you
trust their friends because also it's
you your due diligence as your you know
your partner's partner to get to know
her friends and to understand who she
likes hanging out with because she
probably wants that too and if you can
trust everybody and they're all going
out to the club and she wants to have a
good time I feel like there's nothing
wrong with that but if you set this now
ultimatum but if you make this apparent
and it's a boundary at this boundary
apparent in the beginning of the
relationship such as hey if we're dating
I don't want you going to the club it
makes me uncomfortable uh would you do
me the respect of not going to the club
I think that's fine because that's just
a preference at that point right and I
think all preferences are probably never
been to a club yeah website Club yeah
people dance well
drink
what does that lead to dancing and
drinking sex that is one of the
potential outcomes but that that's not a
one-to-one ratio it's not like you just
so here's the thing I did it here's I
think this is where I disconnected you
can dance and do that this is where the
disconnect is disconnect is this I think
you guys grossly underestimate like how
easy it is for women to get sex and
since it's easy for women to get sex a
threshold for them to cheat is also
easier as well it's a slide a skill that
works together like for men it's very
difficult to get sex doesn't mean they
always want sex though because it's
always available it doesn't mean they're
going to take it but here's my thing
yeah I look at it if your girl is out
dressed provocatively and seeking
attention that is cheating and some
people might look at me like whoa what
do you mean it's because men and women
are different a man has to actually go
out there put his nuts on the line talk
to a girl to initiate some type of
interaction women don't do that women
rarely if ever approach men how do they
do it they do it by exposing their
sexuality men show their Charisma women
show their bodies how would that be any
different from a guy driving down with
like you know a Bentley convertible with
a nice watch on because you still got to
put in work you still have to put in
work to get that girl even though the
Bentley and the watch all it does it
gives you another 20 seconds to to that
is to build attraction if anything like
it's still very difficult as a man even
let's say you got a Bentley and a nice
watch and everything else like that a
girl will still curb you like but a girl
on the other hand she could go into a
club going ah and dudes will still smash
her but if you go into the club you
gonna go to jail you know what I mean
like it's not to say I think if you do
that with confidence you walk it through
me I do they're gonna be like yeah
waiver
because that is who you are but the
thing is is that so people hate this but
the reality is there is a double
standard men and women are not the same
there's behaviors that are completely
unacceptable for women and there's
behaviors that are completely
unacceptable for men and that's okay and
my thing is is that women get mad at
double standards that don't benefit them
that's where they complain about
so I wanted to point out a couple things
do you notice how guys that are more
blue pill always use partner in their
language because again they're in a more
egalitarian model we are equal like that
that is their mindset and I I really
think I was trying to think of a similar
equivalent of a woman going to a club
and I was thinking maybe a man on a
dating app but even that isn't the same
um because again you're putting a girl
in a situation where men like you're
basically saying go to this club where
50 men are gonna try to sleep with you
at the same time why do women feel
entitled to acting the same way in a
relationship as you do single
and it's interesting because we expect
men to change when they're single like I
don't think most women want their guy
going to a strip club they don't want
their guy you know going on boys trips
but we expect to be able to go to a club
like my question is if this is a woman
you want to be a wife and a mother why
does she want to be in the club while
dating you and it's interesting too they
don't really have a firm grasp on female
nature and I used to I used to find this
a little offensive so I kind of
understand like when you first hear it
it sounds trigger triggering but it's
like women we are so easy to to
propagate like they Elites have known
this for over a hundred years women if
you just tell us things like get in our
ear you can literally convince us of
goddamn anything I mean look it we we
could be anything for because of
feminism feminism said women you can do
whatever you want and a lot of us just
decided to go be horse
that that was the best outcome like
think of this this is how easy to
maneuver and manipulate so what
and and it and it shows in the data like
women are much more likely to get
divorced when their friends get divorced
there's a reason that we follow fashion
trends right
women are like packed animals and if you
get the wrong group of women the wrong
chick in her ear women just kind of go
left and the point that Myron is making
is that
why would you put a girl in a situation
that is going to compromise your
relationship like why would you allow a
woman to constantly put herself in
situations that compromise her
relationships there's nothing wrong with
getting to know her friends but if her
friends want to go to the club all of
the time what does that say about her
and I think a wise woman limits
you know the type of friends she brings
around and the friends understand that
you're not going to move the same way in
a relationship that you would single
it's kind of a more like egalitarian
model we are the same where Myron has a
more
um
hierarchy I mean he doesn't flat out say
this but again it's it's that the woman
should follow his lead and a girl that
is going to be in a relationship with
him has to operate under his rules and I
think that relationships would be more
successful if men had this mindset but
the problem is we tell men that they
should just accept anything in a
relationship that a woman can act
exactly the same in a relationship as
she does single and it's like if a girl
goes to a club she's going to have a
bunch of dudes hitting on her if a guy
goes to a club like
I mean he might get eyes maybe if he's
good looking it's it's just not the same
imagine our mothers I mean some of
y'all's mothers maybe did do this
imagine our grandmothers and her
great-grandmothers arguing for the right
to go to the club
that's what we're arguing for
and that's what we've convinced the men
to defend us for doing
a right to go to the club and the whole
point is a woman may be a good woman but
even a good woman around the wrong
friends can be a bad woman and it's kind
of it's the guy's responsibility
if she's operating under his rules
to really protect us from ourselves to
be honest because we just like get
around a group of people we get the
wrong social media thrown at us and we
just think things and start believing
things now I don't say this to be mean
but guys it's just when you interview
hundreds of women and they all have like
the same conclusion that's like men are
abusers like where did we get this idea
that the men are the abusers propaganda
it's not in real life where did we get
this idea that
women are equal to men where because
it's not in society it's very clear when
we look around in real life and who runs
and operates Society it is the men but
yet still in our head we are equal still
in our head these men are these abusers
these grapists when it's not real but
what they'll do is they'll just get in
our ear and they'll do it in school
they'll get in our ear they'll they'll
take over our institutions with all the
studies and say this is a a study that
says something that's not true they'll
get in our ear they'll get in our ear
for social media get in our ear they'll
brainwash all of our friends get in our
ear and then boom
we're on only fans at 37 years old you
have open relationships like all of this
craziness is following the woman's lead
it's not following the man's lead
because men are a lot more logical women
we operate on emotions first we want to
fit in and I think evolutionarily like
we had to fit in in order to survive but
you know maybe I'm crazy
maybe your girlfriend should just go to
the club
send her to the club and have a happy
healthy relationship well guys
um
at to conclude today let your chick go
to the club just let her send her have
fun
um also women have very valid reasons
for divorce and I'm just a big meanie
bad guy Pearl's just a big meanie
who just doesn't know what she's talking
about see there's no trends at all in
society I'm just a big meanie